what is up fellow Geeks today we have
these sponsor SquarePants The Cosmic
Shake BFF Edition we have it on the
Nintendo switch this game will be coming
out on the Playstation Xbox and PC so
let's see what's inside but first let's
take off the plastic real quick and then
we'll take a quick tour of the box so
first things first
on the side it shows us what we have
inside the box that's an inflatable
Patrick it's about 50 cm but we can do
it later on and there is a costume Pack
DLC set of full costume miniature
bouncing balls you'll see them later on
BFF emulate with necklace and a set of
four placemats I wonder how that's going
to play out at the back here you know
just game information and all that stuff
in different languages and on the side
this is the piece that was the storms
this is the cosmic Victory statue I'm
pretty sure you guys know exactly which
scene this is from any Die Hard
SpongeBob fan or there will know exactly
where this is from
[Applause]
[Music]
so let's just slide this out
all right first things first let's just
cut this little piece of plastic around
here
then okay first thing we have is a
certificate of authenticity we got
number 10 094 out of 11 000. there's a
kind of show this is the costume that
you get the DLC code is where I'm
covering right now you got the main game
but now we're going to get to the good
bits so let's just pop out this piece of
extra plastic first thing you'll see is
the BFF necklace down here here are the
four miniature balls with mini
SpongeBobs inside you got SpongeBob as a
pirate you got SpongeBob it's a night
you got SpongeBob in his little karate
sparring outfit and the last one you
have SpongeBob as a cowboy next up are
the placements
so oh they're pretty hefty actually so
you get four of these but we'll just
open it up later on pretty interesting
so far
this is the inflatable Patrick we'll
obviously be inflating him as well this
I believe is a stand for the four balls
let's put this aside
all right here comes the big boy
and
ah
oh that's that's pretty big
uh
foreign
here we have the cosmic Victory statue
it's about 24 cm and let's just get into
looking at everything we got okay so
this is pretty much everything you'll
get inside the box it may not seem like
a lot but trust me it is a lot to take
out so let's just look at the BFF
necklace real quick it comes a little
classic back it's quite Hefty actually
so let's just kind of push in the locket
like that nice little button on here and
I think should pop right open oh it does
and oh so you got SpongeBob and Patrick
down here in the little Cosmic theme you
know it is the cosmic shake and we have
a cute little drawing of Patrick and
SpongeBob the inside there is nothing
much here this is just the latch for
this thing next up are the placemats so
they come in all nice little pasta
packagings these things are very
reflective let's just take this one out
you got SpongeBob running a seahorse
with this hair flowing in the wind and
it's really reflective it's actually
quite hard
it is very hot actually and you have
plastic Stoppers at the bottom for its
legs so you know it doesn't slip off we
have a combination of Gary and SpongeBob
we also have caveman SpongeBob right
here and we got the Flying Dutch point
in a little Halloween themed bikini
bottom so you get four of these you know
the pretty
they're pretty damn bouncy
so these four balls of SpongeBob inside
them with different costumes and I'd say
that the build quality on the models
inside of them are actually really nice
especially with the shield and a little
nice Helm down here and even SpongeBob
little lasso right here but the cool
thing is the BFF Edition actually comes
with a stand to display the ball so
let's just do that you got a nice little
bit of acrylic down here with exactly
four holes to fit all four balls and I
don't think you can remove this brown
piece off it kind of just stays there
okay so you can't remove the brown piece
out but honestly I don't think that's a
huge issue so let's just put them all on
and I'd say the build quality on the
acrylic base is actually pretty good
because nothing is coming off even if
you give it a little shake and before we
move on to the next bit here's a message
from a sponsor secret lab this video is
brought to you by secret lab here at
geek culture we love our secret lectures
especially the all-new 2022 Titan Evo
with its revamped four-way lumbar system
for enhance back support if bu leather
took 2.0 isn't your cup of tea then
consider the all-new soft weave even
more soft and breathable than before the
chair comes in more colors including
this lovely Frost blue the Tyson Evo is
even magnetized allowing the hit pillow
to stick on the headrest of course there
are even more new features so do check
them out at secretlab.co alright so now
we're back let's just open up this main
bit down here here's the main game let's
see what's inside so open this up oh
okay there's nothing much inside except
just the cartridge you know so kind of
wish those small things inside here but
it is what it is and of course with the
DLC costume pack down here can't show
the code that's for us but here are the
costumes you will get in the DLC next up
the second biggest piece in this entire
collection
is the Fatal Patrick which will take a
bit more effort to set up
opening this up there isn't like any
sort of pump that comes with it so if
you have a pump that'd be great but I'll
just be doing it manually I'll just be
blowing through this mouse piece down
here all right so after opening up
Patrick the star I'd say that the
it's actually pretty good it's not too
big not too small so let's just inflate
Patrick up
all right so we have Patrick inflicted
in his full Glory he's actually pretty
good this can be used as English
decorations if you want to take him to
the pool you know it's really Nifty
really good quality and like the thing
is the printing and everything on here
looks really neat so let's move on to
the main piece which is the cosmic
Victory statue let's take him out right
so let's look at the Box you got him at
the front here on the sides just small
branding in the back you know just got a
full graphic of him down here and then
pretty much yeah that's about it right
let's open him up there's a little bit
of tape here you need to cut off so
handy knife
and just a zip or let us unveil him
right very nice nice little SpongeBob
graphics on the front down here really
love that touch right and then slowly
remove them
and
here we have him in this full Glory
box is pretty nice though I gotta say a
lot of SpongeBob imagery down here in
all this goofy stuff I think they're all
just sketches but they're all just
really nice
let's put the Box aside oh there's more
tape here you cut it off
nope right
and then
you can't take it out it comes as a
whole piece as far as I can tell and
let's just remove this main plastic down
here and look at him right so here the
main piece down here Patrick is just
hanging on the side and so it's really
hanging off the side right here he does
Jiggle a little bit we got eyes and a
mouth on here can't remember where
that's from if it's a reference from the
show but I guess it's a reference to the
game which you'll find out when you do
play it and we have SpongeBob here gonna
hit a sick note if you guys remember the
scene everyone should remember the scene
by now
[Music]
and let's just turn him around it
honestly comes as is there is nothing
else you need to assemble so right out
of the box this is what you get so let's
just do an overview of everything we
have all right folks so what you see is
what you get we have covered everything
inside the box there is nothing else
inside there that hasn't been covered
and I'd say it's pretty comprehensive
with the placemats the inflatable
Patrick the game the DLC the locket
which I really love the certificate of
authenticity the balls and the acrylic
stand and of course the statue so if you
guys have any questions leave them in
the comment section down below and I'll
do my best to get to them but make sure
you follow us on all of our socials here
to keep up to date with what we have
going on and of course if you like this
video be sure to hit that like button
and subscribe to us it goes a long way
and if you like this video check this
out
foreign
[Music]